[Music]
chess bit 64.
okay he's got one bar of connection so
let's hope so the connection remains and
of course we are playing a smith mora
and we are seeing how the mora holds up
at this level
and it is accepted
e6 knight f3
a6 bishop c4 this is theory b5 bishop b3
this i know but the rest i don't i know
we're supposed to castle here
and then at some point we're supposed to
just slam a knight onto d5 but i don't
remember
exactly where
that's the thing
i know we're supposed to play knight t5
but i don't remember where there's also
queen e2 rook t1 of course queen e2 rook
d1 might be the move here it makes a lot
of sense i like the i like the look of
queen e2 and we will consult esserman
after the game so queen e2 makes a lot
of sense here
if you watch me play the more you will
know that
this particular rearrangement of heavy
pieces
is considered very effective because the
rook x-rays the queen the white queen
x-rays the black king
and it makes possible
uh and increases the effectiveness of
various sacrifices in the center
most prominently a move like knight d5
what i mean the big question in these
types of positions is is always when
what is the right moment
for knight d5 there's also bishop d5
that is a lot more infrequent but is
also a sack that has to be reckoned with
so knight t5 is
incredibly tempting here the point is if
he takes d5 we play e takes d5 check
what seems to be
a very serious attack against his king
95 but knight takes b3 i really didn't
want to give this bishop away we can
also play knight e5
knight f6
bishop g5 d6
then we have a sack on b5
oh
that looks
spicy i have a spicy idea
so this pawn is is a weakness obviously
my idea is to go let's try it this
seems dubious but we're going to give it
a shot we're going to start with the
move knight e5 exploiting the fact that
black's knight is no longer on c6
now we're gonna add the pressure with
bishop g5
reinforcing the threat of knight takes
d7 now it's a threat again because the
black knight is pinned so after we take
on d7 black will not be able to
recapture because they will lose the
queen
well my idea i think i'm i'm pretty
happy with which is d6
opens up the a4 e8 diagonal
and so it makes possible very thematic
sacrifice on b5
uh we're trying to attack from all sides
here
we're basically trying to attack from
all sides and after knight takes b5 i
have no idea what's going on
but that is the fun of the mora is
occasional chaos
knight e5 takes f7 up off and have oh
yeah
by the way we do have knight takes f7
and e5 if if black plays d6 oh my god we
also have some cool ideas with a double
sacrifice knight f7 bishop takes c6 and
e5
but that seems a little bit over the top
anyways knight takes b3
so we should briefly consider what
happens if we don't take on b3 because
there is the move knight takes d7
there's even rook takes d7
so let's calculate rook takes d7
queen d7 knight d7 knight a1
black has too many pieces there
for the rook
black has too many pieces for the rook
if we play knight takes d7
black plays knight takes a1 we take the
queen
that looks a lot better though
oh knight takes d7
the problem there though is that black
can play a move like queen c7 we can
only take one piece at once no i think i
think we should just take let's not
let's not do anything
insane
yeah this is a very cool idea putting
the knight on e5 and then attacking this
pawn but also
and i'll show this idea after the game
this is what mark is mentioning knight
takes f7 and e5
um
opening up the black king and re and
winning back the knight on f6
so obviously the attack isn't the same
without the bishop on b3
you know we've still got
one two three and potentially
four and five pieces in the
direct attack against black's king
yeah d6 knight b5 queen b6
there's got to be a move there though
okay so let's calculate knight takes b5
queen b6
do we have
an idea there must be something
now we also have knight f7 here but it's
it's not the same without the bishop
maybe knight d5
that's a little too crazy even for me
though
so what i'm trying to figure out is a
response to knight knight p5 and queen
b6 so there is knight d6 and knight c4
i mean we can risk it anyway but i our
position is not like
does not warrant it
okay here's what we're going to do we're
going to compromise
no we're not going to compromise
we're going to go knight g4
now we're going to have to step back i
mean actually the knight wasn't even
hanging so maybe a rook d3
or something would have been
better yeah no i got a little
discombobulated here
i'll show you after the game why knight
xb5 didn't work a good spot by mark
i'm really bummed this idea failed but
maybe we'll be able to produce some
fireworks here
still
h6 that's a that's got to be a mistake
so rather than developing black is
allowing us to ruin
his structure oh and now
now the idea with knight takes b5
is going to be a heck of a lot
more justified but again he's got
something take stakes
knight takes b5 there's h5 inter mezzo
and if we move our knight back then
black takes on b5
geez louise so in that case so the big
question here is what should take on f6
what i can't seem to decide is what to
take on f6 with i'm inclined
i'm gonna i'm inclined to take with the
bishop i think most of you most of you
guys want to do that too
and drop the bishop back to f4 in order
to launch a direct assault
against black's weakest pawn and of
course
we are trying to bishop f6 and knight t5
oh yeah that could have been interesting
but bishop g7 i guess
the problem if we're left with just two
knights is just that
we need a bishop in order to chisel away
at black's
central pawn mass now you might notice
that this
particular pawn structure occurs also in
openings like the rouser sicilian but
this is not unknown in the sicilian goes
h5
so again knight takes b5 fails because
of ab5 queen b5 and for instance bishop
c6 so what is the stock plan the typical
plan that we employ
to attack the d6 pawn well
we know what that plan is nothing new
under the sun we double our rooks we
play rook d2 and rook 81
and you might look at this and so i
don't get it can't black just play the
move e5
and ward away
the ship on f4 and black cannon maybe
even should in some cases but that
creates a gaping hole in the d5 score
which i'm happy
to accept that kind of position b4
okay well we need to move our knight
where do we move it
well we can move it to a4 for instance
that's as good of a square as any at
least it's defended and i'm very much
hoping that one day we get a chance to
play the move knight b6
and the thing is i'm sure pr i'm sure
the engine will probably evaluate this
in black's favor but these positions are
incredibly tough to play
because yeah long-term weakness of
black's king we have very obvious
attacking ideas such as
doubling rooks on the d file trying to
provoke e5 although e5 is probably a
really good move now wow
we have to play bishop e3 but the good
thing about that move is we're preparing
knight b6 now
now we have access to the b6 square
so i feel like we're actually
making progress here despite appearances
now we we are dropping potentially the
pawn on e4 i don't care about pawns you
can't play this line
and really care about the pawn count in
any given moment
we're not playing for pawns here we're
playing for
for checkmate
is the hole on d5 still good well of
course the fact that it exists is good
and if we play knight b6
then we will have access
to
to that gaping hole on d5
what are we going to do after bishop
takes d4 well the way i see it we have
two choices if bishop takes e4 happens
some of you might be tempted by the move
bishop b6 which is
not a good move because the queen can
slide over to b7 and attack the pawn at
the same time f5 by our opponent
i don't think that's a great move
okay i see what black is trying to do
he's trying to get
he's trying to activate the bishop
now we have a couple of choices here
but it realistically we only have one
choice we need to take this one we need
to get rid of it
so that
we don't have to deal with the headache
of moves like f5 f4
now my guess is
he's banking on rook g8
um
but then we can respond to the move f3
and i'm just not seeing where black's
counter attack is
yeah this is a sevesnikov style idea the
problem is that black's king is so weak
here we have such pressure on the on the
d-pawn and by the way why did i not play
g3 who can tell me
why not g3 in this position
yeah now now we're we're in phenomenal
shape
because of queen c6 yeah because g3
creates a much more long-lastic and
long-lasting and exploitable weakness on
this diagonal
okay so this doesn't even really create
any threats this is a great example of
something i mentioned earlier which is
that at this level
you need to stop being
reactive so i can guarantee you that
most of you are
thinking about h3 in your minds
but this is a paper tiger
we can just go along with our plan and
play knight p6 if black plays h3 big
f d we just play g3 or even g4 but i
think g3 is better
and black doesn't have the firepower to
exploit that okay rook d8
here it's important to think in terms of
drawbacks
what effect on the position does the
move rook d8 however the rook used to be
on the c file the c file is an open file
and as i've repeated again and again
when there is only one open file on the
chessboard you want to make sure that
you control that file so the move rook
c2 comes to mind we play that move and
we blunder bishop takes f3
um which is
not good
at all
the moment i played it i realized that
he doesn't see it
that was a sloppy little one bishop f3
would not have won the game or anything
but it would have complicated the game
and now hannah thank you for the five
oh that's so sweet
and i will definitely throw you the rate
if you're still streaming
hmm how much should we do here
it's actually not so simple to put the
finishing touches on the game let's play
positionally let's go knight d5
let's play positionally drop the knight
back to d5 what bothers me is the state
of this bishop this bishop was exerting
some annoying pressure
on the f3 pawn
so we're going to drop our knight back
to d5 try to induce a trade
and then keep infiltrating down the c
file
down the d i mean something is going to
give here for black there's no way that
black will hold this position
together for more than five moves
hopefully okay so now the move h3 is
even less effective like i said g4 or g3
both moves are
totally fine let's go g4 because in the
absence of the light squared bishop
yeah now g4 is fully justified i think
i had queen f3 and rook c1 and bishop of
three okay we'll take a look after the
game
so apparently bishop takes f3 was not
effective
so what is the plan here how do you
actually win such a position
you win by infiltrating okay you can
also win by taking free pawns that our
opponent is
leaving by the side of the
road i don't see a reason not to grab
this little baby on a6
yeah the sort of narrative of this
entire game is that black's king has
never found a home
and positions where your king is
permanently weak are just objectively
very difficult to play even if the
computer evaluates them at one point or
another as being better okay so this is
last ditch efforts by black to
complicate the game not bad
actually not bad we have to be careful
here
so let me see if i can figure out
an effective winning approach here
so we can go rook b5 but then black
plays queen a8
there's got to be a win here
we can play queen c6 king
f7 rook b5
queen a8
rook b7 bishop e7 queen d5 and rook
cc7 i think
the winning approach is to give this
weird-looking check on c6
and the purpose of this move is to drag
the black king to f7 now you might say
well isn't that a good thing for black
isn't black now closer to escaping but
if you look concretely we are now
getting the rook to b7 by force
and that check is going to be utterly
devastating
utterly devastating
okay queen a8
now another check
bishop has to cover
now who can tell me
what white should do now
now we win by force
now in such positions the easiest method
is just to look for checks because
statistically it is a lot likelier that
the winning move is going to come with
check as you guys are indicating we
slide the queen back to d5 creating
contact with the black rook on g8 and
that's going to be the key to the
winning move in this position the rook
is a type 2 undefended piece it's
defended only by the king so using that
logic we find the move bishop h6 check
and this ends the game
so a simple attack just every single
piece is participating maybe with the
exception of the rook on c2 but that
rook was the engine
that got the attack going
all right
there's a lot to talk about and again
you know people especially watching on
youtube getting overwhelmed by
the level of these games like be patient
i will try to explain all of my logic
after the game
and
let's start with a little theoretical
overview
so this was amora
so black played the e6 a6 variation
which is
as far as i can tell one of the better
better lines from an objective
standpoint i think the engine is a fan
of this line
i think the engine is a fan of this line
so here
here here
so b5 bishop b3 bishop b7
castles x clam and now knight c6
i think knight c6 is supposed to be
in inaccuracy right
so knight c6 this is a weird looking
move because it blocks the bishop
with before his chapter four got it
knight c6 is still oh it's analyzed okay
so what is the move here
after knight c6
so of course the point is if black plays
before we go knight t5
if black plays b4 then white goes knight
t5 and this sacrifices
without the sacrifice the morals simply
wouldn't exist
so knight c6 is an interesting move find
the position of bishop d5
yeah so this exact position i don't see
i see queenie two knight c6 oh queen
okay there we go queen e2
queenie two transposes to a position
from your game against boris kreiman
this transposes to a position from your
game against crimean the move is rookie
one here uh-huh
so i played
oh i did play queenie two
i did play queenie two so this actually
is exactly your position against crimean
castle's knight g if he would have
played knight g7 then bishop g5
f6 or fd1
thank you not a staple for the prime so
you get this crazy position
sacrificing
the bishop on g5
and getting wow rook takes d7 jesus
queen takes d7 bishop takes c6 but this
is very scary for black
this is very very scary for black
but the bottom line is that this is a
really entertaining line
so apparently the move here is rookie
one
and
rookie one sets up the idea of knight d5
by creating the x-ray against the king
so rookie one d6
a4
inducing b4
and now knight d5
this looks
incredibly juicy
this looks incredibly juicy since we're
at this high level
i will say that
i will say that
what i would do if i were
sort of playing a very serious game is i
would spend probably 15-20 minutes
analyzing with with a high-level
stockfish
and using
the material
at uh at my disposal so in this case the
book and i would try to really get to
the bottom
really get to the bottom of the
variation now obviously when you analyze
the mora with stockfish a lot of times
it's giving
you know 0.3.4 for black but
you cannot you cannot conclude anything
on the basis of computer evaluations
because imagine having this position
with black
just any takers in the chat to having
this position with black
or like he takes d5 he takes d5 check i
don't think so
if bishop oh if bishop e7 here bishop e3
threatening bishop b6
and knight c7 check and if he takes d5
suddenly you take with the queen
that's really cool and you cannot defend
the f7 pawn in fact there is a
well you can get mated here in about two
seconds
so
black is in a lot of trouble here
very interesting
oh you had a game like this oh my god
robert perez uh-huh
yeah black can probably resign already
after queen takes d5 very cool so the
move is rookie one for mora fanatics the
move is rookie one here in order to set
up knight d5
but let's take a look at the game i
played queen e2
rook c8 was played
by our opponent which is
a reasonable improving move we go rick
d1 now i played this in the same way
that you play the main line
i played this in the same way you played
the main line where did i take queenie
to rook d1
um sure
okay so you had a game against perez
let me pull up the entire game
knight before queen b6
okay so this is after
okay is this a do you mean this is after
queen d5
oh oh oh you mean
okay rookie one b4 knight t5 knight a5
knight
b4
um queen b6
okay
so this tries to skewer the pieces along
the b file
yeah this tries to skewer the pieces
along the b file and now apparently
there's some sort of move
okay so white to play here will bishop
d2 makes sense to defend the knight
but maybe there's something more
tactical
that's what i meant about knight c6
hiding in the book oh i see i see
but all right so
but let's let's take a look at queenie
two because
the
the course of the game actually led to
some very interesting complications as
well
so queen e2
rook c8
rook d1 knight a5
yeah and this seems to be a critical
moment uh so bishop d5
bishop d5 would have been possible here
as well
85
85 check
i thought about this but somehow
on queen b6 you mean
oh you mean in that line queen b6 bishop
d5
oh shoot
bishop d5 here
queen takes b4 bishop d2 is the idea aha
i see what you're saying
queen b6
bishop takes a five queen takes a5 and
bishop takes b7
yeah that's really cool bishop d5 in
this position
so rook c8 rook d1
knight a5
and now i decided to
harass the pawn on d7
so of course there is the alternative
idea of putting the bishop on d5 i'm not
sure exactly why i rejected it i felt
like this position was inconvincing
was unconvincing but here for example
there's the move queen f1
here for example there's the move queen
f1 threatening rookie one and it feels
like white's got a huge attack
so
probably bishop d5 was objectively
better
but i missed this one tiny detail and
because of it this entire line kind of
falls by the wayside so 95
so the purpose of this move is to attack
d7
and the secondary idea is that if black
plays d6
then
there is this tactic with knight takes
b5
there's this tactic with knight takes b5
so so the point is you want the queen to
be on d1 so that it is able to take on
d5
yeah this extra tempo gives black makes
it a lot less likely than stuff like
knight t5 works
and if a takes b5 then queen takes b5
check you get this kind of position with
a huge attack against the gang
what i missed is that in these types of
positions black has the tactic with
queen b6 or counter-tactic with queen b6
maybe not specifically here but in
general and both knights are hanging and
in some cases there's no way to get
compensation for the piece
so
black plays knight f6
black plays not f6
we play bishop g5 to reinforce the
pressure on d on d7
okay we have a trade on b3
and i was also considering
the move rook takes d7 briefly
but you always have to remember that
when you're going after your opponent's
queen and you're giving up a million
pieces
uh very often a situation arises where
the opposing side just has way too many
pieces for the queen this is a great
example of that
the simplest the black can do here is
knight takes d7
bishop takes the eight and knight takes
a one
and black has a rook or two rooks and a
piece for the for the queen
which is way too much material
way too much material
so for that reason we have to recapture
d6 and this was the critical moment in
the entire game this is where i missed
that if we play knight takes b5
again the same idea if a b then queen
takes b5 wins the game because this is a
fork
and the knight on e5 makes it impossible
for black to play queen b7
and the bishop punchy five makes it
impossible to play knight t7
this is completely winning but black has
this crazy move queen v6
and i was unable to find any response to
this any adequate response to this the
problem is that if you move this knight
black captures the other one
if you move the e knight black captures
the b knight
the only thing i saw here was knight
takes d6 check
bishop takes d6 and knight c4 with a
fork
but the problem here is that black can
play rook takes c4 of course and black
has two pieces for a rook it's not
losing it's probably even
maybe it is losing black has two pieces
for a rook
and incredibly placed minor pieces this
is not appetizing at all
this is not how you go down in the moral
you don't do something like this and die
with a whimper
so for that reason
we veer off with the move knight g4
and it i think it is very important to
be able to improvise
reasonably when your main idea doesn't
work
i think this is a precursor for a
blunder for most people
the situation where you know you go for
a long line
and then at the end of the line you
realize that your main idea doesn't work
so
for instance we realize that knight
takes b5 doesn't work but rather than
panicking and doing it anyway for
example you have to make the most out of
a tough situation
so knight f7 and e5 is another idea that
some of you saw
but here black has the very typical
response h6
bishop h4 and g5 black keeps the extra
piece
yeah you cannot just
look at
you know
aim for one idea it doesn't work and
then you just
crumble and sack all your pieces
randomly so knight e4 is a good example
of that because this keeps the pressure
going
while avoiding any unnecessary
sacrifices
now truth be told i think if black just
plays the simple bishop e7 white is
probably worse not probably white is
definitely worse but the game continues
the game is not over
and i think the best the most
clinical thing white can do here
is probably just take on f6
now if black plays gf then this is kind
of like what happened in the game i
would never mind playing such a
structure especially here maybe knight
h6 and queen h5 is interesting but if
bishop takes f6 then we play knight
takes f6 check
again if gf then the game continues and
if queen takes f6
unfortunately knight takes b5 doesn't
work but you play rook takes d6 and life
goes on
you play rook takes t6 you win back the
pawn
and life completely goes on probably the
position is very close to equal hair i
don't think white is
significantly worse if worse at all
so probably objectively black should
play g takes f6 but okay queen h5
and black's king is never going to be
safe
so
i i don't know if that makes sense but
but this ability to improvise is very
important
so knight for h6 by our opponent
which kind of fans the flames of the
attack because it allows us to get a
super desirable pawn structure and to
keep our dark squared bishop which is
the primary instrument of attacking the
d6 pawn so bishop f4
so h5 by our opponent
probably trying to stop our queen from
getting to h5 not a very good use of
black's time
i think our opponent should have focused
instead on completing his development
bishop e7 is her development with bishop
b7
after h5
we embark on the main plan which is to
attack the d6 pawn
okay b4 by our opponent and the move
knight a4 another important detail
right how did i know that it was a good
idea to put the knight on the rim here
well i could anticipate that eventually
our knight would have access to the b6
square and the knight is defended by a
pawn so it won't be a headache with
respect to
forks and stuff and i appreciate the
opening inside by the way from mark from
mark it's always nice to have the
world's leading expert at an opening in
the chat we played at a4
and also there were no alternatives like
no other square was appetizing and the
sacrifice on d5 in my opinion is no
longer as effective because we simply
don't have any minor pieces left
i mean black can probably go bishop e7
here
tuck the king away on f8 and i'm just
not sensing sufficient compensation for
the piece here
if that makes sense so by process of
elimination i mean what you're going to
go back to d1
a4 is the only appetizing square queen
c7 we complete the doubling with rook 81
e5 we dropped the bishop back to e3 very
important this sets up knight b6
and if black had played bishop takes e4
we basically have a choice of two moves
here
the move i don't like is queen takes a6
because
black has for instance the move queen b7
and this essentially forces the queen
trade because if i doesn't trade you
give up the pawn on g2 which you cannot
afford to give up
now even after the queen trade it's not
the end of the world white continues but
this is not in the spirit of the moor i
didn't want to allow this
and so for that reason i think our move
here would have been to start with
knight b6
and
the point that i wanted to make here
this is a very important point is that
in such positions
you can simply place slowly down two
puns i would claim
that
white's position is probably not worse
here objective practically speaking
because we've got such control over the
center black has this permanently weak
king on e8
and uh it's just much harder to play
with black here than with white and it's
a very important thing to understand if
you want to be a gambit player you have
to be okay
with just playing down upon or even down
a piece
and not necessarily
you know having some sort of checkmate
within three moves if that makes
sense
you just got to be able to say okay i've
got this is the notion of long-term
compensation that a lot of people
struggle to understand
long-term compensation basically means i
don't know
exactly
where my attack is going to be but i've
got these long-term pluses that are
going to give me compensation for a very
very long time and long-term
compensation can be in the form of weak
squares it can be in the form of a
permanently weak king which is the case
here because even if black castles
kingside kingside is no safer than the
center so something to chew on if you're
like an 1800 player the notion of
long-term compensation is something that
is illustrated by this game i think f5
is the beginning of the end i think
giving away this pawn
yeah our opponent tried to open the
diagonal for their bishop but
after f3
black's quote unquote initiative ends
and this pawn is a pretty big asset
that can potentially move into f6
and black's position just crumbles
completely here h4 knight b6
um rook d8 we get our rook to the open c
file we move our knight back to d5 as
planned to get rid of black's last good
piece
and then
i mean this position is completely
winning we're dominating on all sides
now maybe black didn't defend as best as
he could maybe queen b7
was a little bit more resilient but we
would have played queen c4 and it's only
a matter of time before we get to
black's king
oh yeah i was going to show bishop takes
f3 which i missed after rook c2 but
according to mark yeah there's
so bishop takes f3 is something that i
overlooked this is a deflection
sacrifice
or deflection tactic rather
because if we take the queen then black
takes our queen
but there is a very pretty idea queen
takes f3 queen takes c2 and rook c1
ah but here black might have e4
oh my god the point of rook c1 is that
if black just moves back to d3 then
there's a check on c6 and this is
crushing knight d5 check
and this wins
this wins the queen
so this would have been winning on the
spot but e4
is problematic
queen f1 there's queen d3 it's still
unclear i still probably would take
white here
yeah e4 is such a funny move
i guess we can play queen h3
black will probably play queen e2
and then maybe we can find some so and
then maybe knight d5 for example
even this position is very difficult to
play with black
even this position is very difficult to
play with back i don't think black is
winning here
i i definitely don't think black is
winning here
yeah i mean this knight dominates the
board we're threatening knight f6 now
perhaps black can play queen d3 to
prevent knight d5
but then
we maybe play oh oh my god there's such
a beautiful idea there's f6 look at this
line
f6 d5
rook c7 and let's say black plays d4 who
can find
the gorgeous mating idea
who can find the gorgeous mating idea
come on guys queen e6 bang
f7 checkmate
this is what you get when you play
gambits
these kinds of ideas and the crazy thing
is
this might be the objectively best move
rook c7
because if queen b1 check
king f2
uh but maybe black has bishop d6 here
and queen e6 check no longer works
that's sad
takes check
f8 oh it's almost made but black
survives
but you can see the kinds of ideas that
white has in this position
which means that the game is very very
far from over
very very far from
over i mean f6 d5
you should even consider queen c8 here
although that doesn't work queen takes
e3 as chuck
so
plenty of
rich tactical ideas even when we're down
this much material but i don't think i
should have allowed bishop takes f3 i
think that the immediate knight d5 might
have been objectively better
but in any case rook c2 we got a little
fortunate this was the smith moral lily
this was the smith moro knight d5
trade
and f6 queen takes a6 is game over i
mean this is really easy
after e4 nice little idea to play queen
c6 check
yeah who would ever write a book about
that game but with the idea of forcing
the king onto f7 so that this move comes
with check right just like
simple attacking
simple straightforward attacking chess
simple straightforward attacking chess
and uh bishop h6 jack just ends it
yeah so this was a pretty i mean 33
moves but a lot happened in those 33
moves
to summarize in the opening we come to
the conclusion that rook e1 is much more
accurate than the way i played it
than the way i played it queen e2
invests an extra tempo
in
the setting up of this heavy piece
formation
and that tempo
is not something that white can afford
in a lot of different lines because it
allows black to make one of these really
annoying moves such as knight a5 and you
want to keep this bishop alive for as
long as possible so that's a good
insight
about playing this opening at a deeper
level rook c8 rook d1
not a5
and then we went for
this false
idea of trying to induce d6 so that we
can sack on b5 was a really cool idea
but it doesn't seem to
to do the trick bishop g5
takes takes t6 now the importance of
improvising and not losing your mind
when one of your ideas
doesn't work so that's the notion of the
move knight g4 then we saw the
importance of long-term compensation
and uh the rest of the game from this
point on was pretty straightforward
doubling rooks in order to attack d6 was
an important plan
yeah bishop c2 the bishop becomes
ineffective
right you want to keep it's basically
either you want to keep the bishop on b3
or
the bishop is basically useless a bishop
c2 already is is surrenders the the
initiative completely
it surrenders the initiative completely
yeah definitely a game that can be
analyzed for a lot longer but
it's 3 30.
i'm exhausted i'm sorry if i wasn't as
coherent in this game as i normally am
just because
i'm really really tired enjoy see you
guys tomorrow thanks for hanging out bye
[Music]